IT IS THE BATTLE TO LIBERATE
UKRAINIAN TERRITORY.
ALL EYES TONIGHT ARE ON
STATEMENTS FROM THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSE MINISTER.
HE HAS PUBLICLY ORDERED THE
WITHDRAWAL OF FORCES FROM
KHERSON'S WEST BANK.
IT IS COMES AS UKRAINIAN FORCES
ADVANCE TOWARDS THAT STRATEGIC
CITY FROM TWO DIRECTIONS.
KHERSON HAS BEEN THE ONLY
REGIONAL CAPITAL TAKEN BY
RUSSIA SINCE FEBRUARY'S
INVASION.
I JUST SAT DOWN FOR AN
EXCLUSIVE JOINT INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ANY FIRST
LADY.
I ASKED ABOUT THE STATUS OF
UKRAINIAN COUNTER OFFENSIVE
AGAINST RUSSIANS OCCUPYING
KHERSON.
>> I WILL TRY TO ANSWER IN A
WAY THAT DOES NOT GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER, TO BE HONEST.
THE PLANNED MILITARY ACTIONS
ARE DISCUSSED IN A SMALL CIRCLE.
THEY ARE EXECUTED IN SILENCE.
I REALLY WANT TO HAVE AN
UNPLEASANT SURFACE SURPRISE FOR
THE ENEMY.
NOT SOMETHING THEY ARE PREPARED
FOR.
I WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGIZE.
AT ANY RATE, OUR PEOPLE AND
YOUR PUBLIC NEED TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON SOME VERY
SERIOUS STEPS WITH A POSITIVE
OUTCOME FOR THE CITIZENS OF
UKRAINE.
THERE ARE ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT SUPPORT PEACE
IN UKRAINE.
>> THE PRESIDENT WARNS NOT TO
TAKE A RUSSIAN PUBLIC
STATEMENTS AT FACE VALUE ABOUT
WITHDRAWING FROM KHERSON.
HE SAYS THAT THIS COULD JUST BE
A REGROUP.
THE CONVERSATION TAKES PLACE AS
RESULTS FROM AMERICA'S MIDTERMS
BEGIN TO POUR IN.
THIS IS A VOTE THAT IS BEING
WATCHED HERE AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY TOLD ME
THAT HE HOPES VITAL U.S.
SUPPORT CONTINUES.
>> WE WOULD REALLY LIKE FOR THE
SUPPORT.
ESPECIALLY THE AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT TO STAY THE SAME.
WE WANT TO HAVE THIS JOINT
SUPPORT FROM ANOTHER SOCIETY.
WE WANT THE U.S. TAXPAYERS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS IS
NOT THE MONEY OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS THE MONEY OF THE PEOPLE.
SECONDLY, WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE THIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT REMAIN AFTER
THE ELECTION.
THERE HAS BEEN THESE MIXED
MESSAGES THAT WERE IN THE U.S.
MASS MEDIA.
FOR US, IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
PRESERVE THIS LEVEL OF SUPPORT.
THEY SENT A VERY SIGNIFICANT
AND POWERFUL SIGNAL.
IT HAS AN IMPACT ALSO ON THE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT COMING FROM
THE EU COUNTRIES.
SOME OF THE COUNTRIES ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE EU AS WELL.
WHATEVER THE UNITED STATES
SUPPORTERS --
EUROPE JOINED THIS SUPPORT AS
WELL.
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO, THEN
COMEDIAN VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
AND HIS ARCHITECT --
WIFE OLENA ZELENSKYY COULD
NEVER HAVE GUESSED THEY'D BE
THRUST INTO THE SPOTLIGHT AS
WARTIME PRESIDENT AND A SPOUSE.
BECAUSE OF SECURITY CONCERNS,
THEY DON'T GET TO SPEND MUCH
TIME TOGETHER THESE DAYS.
WHEN WE MET THE THRUST AND
PARITY OF MARITAL LIFE LOVE AND
A SENSE OF HUMOR WERE ALL ON
DISPLAY.
>> WHAT STRENGTH DO YOU GET
FROM EACH OTHER?
>> IF I CAN.
THAT IS MY LOVE AND THAT IS MY
BEST FRIEND.
SO THAT IS MY ENERGY.
I WANTED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
WHEN OLENA TOLD YOU SHE
PREPARED BREAKFAST FOR THE
CHILDREN IN THE MORNING AND
PREPARED CLOTHES AND ET CETERA
AND WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU.
I HAVE NO SUCH POSSIBILITY.
NOBODY GIVES ME BREAKFAST.
IN THE MORNING.
IT'S SUCH A DIFFICULT PERIOD.
>> A NOTE OF HUMOR AMID THE
DARKNESS.
TUNE IN TOMORROW NIGHT TO SEE
THE REST OF THIS INTERVIEW.
A GLOBAL EXPLOSIVE WITH THE
FIRST COUPLE WHO HAVE BECOME
ROLE MODELS FOR THEIR OWN
PEOPLE AND FOR MANY AROUND THE
WORLD.